from exclusive items to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Chinese takeout in the US and
the UK this is food
Wars here are all the menu items you'll
find any UK Chinese Takeaway that you
might not find in the US here is all of
the Chinese takeout we got at our local
spot that you might not be able to find
in the UK we'll start with the
appetizers in the UK it's pretty common
when you order a Chinese to order a few
starters and you kind of eat them
alongside your meal one thing to point
out almost all of these are beige I
think that's going to be a bit of a
theme as we go throughout this episode a
lot of British Chinese food is just kind
of beige fried stuff and we love it
we'll start with an exception to the
beige rule with Crispy seaweed it's
actually got a misleading name because
this isn't seaweed it's shredded cabbage
which is then deep fried it's always
aggressively salty sometimes you get a
little bit of kind of like fish flakes
sprinkled on top I think this one is
basically just fried cabbage with some
salt powder on
it when we had a Chinese Takeaway at
home it would pretty much be the only
green thing on our plates and here's
what we got for our exclusive appetizers
starting with the steamed
dumplings that's so good I love a
dumpling another pretty iconic starter
is a chicken sat skewer they will take a
piece of chicken put it on a skewer
Grill it up in a kind of saté sauce
which is mostly peanuts and then serve
it to you there we also have a bit of
additional saté sauce for dipping as
well these are great they're always like
a little bit dry I think that's why you
have to have the sauce on the side as
well next we have the scallion pancake
which literally looks like a cut up
little pancake I'm GNA take a
taste yeah that's really tasty I want to
dip this in something though I'm like
getting the urge to dip when I think of
a British Chinese Takeaway this might be
one of the main dishes that comes to
mind these are sweet and sour chicken
balls so the sweet and sour bit actually
just refers to the sauce that it's
served with it's basically just a piece
of chicken which is then battered and
deep
fried mhm now these very in quality a
lot from restaurant to restaurant if
chicken balls aren't your thing then we
also have the option of a prawn ball now
instead of a piece of chicken they take
an entire prawn batter it and deep fry
it kind of like a tempura prawn but I
think a lot heavier on the batter we've
been locked in a debate here as to if
there's any difference between prawn and
shrimp it seems like sometimes they're
used interchangeably but maybe they are
actually different species I don't know
if Nico you have any thoughts on the
differences between porn and shrimp
there is actually a difference between
shrimp and crra it's not just linguistic
shrimp are more common in the US and
tend to smaller with a more Savory
flavor when compared to prawns Charlie
is saying that when he's had it in the
past it's been like a sort of prawn
paste mashed up into a ball whereas
these ones are just whole prawns inside
some butter so I feel like I've got a
better deal here this is a fried won
it's so cute it looks like a little
flow that is so good and crunchy next up
I did want to take a look at British
wons I know you can get these in America
but I thought there might be some
differences so these ones are not crispy
these are steamed pretty tasty not
something that I would commonly order
moving on we have the crab rang goons
these are like kind of a meme now for
some reason I don't know why these have
like a spike in popularity just like in
general but this is what they look like
kind of similar to a won but bigger
let's crack this bad boy open oh Gorge
The Filling is just crab and cream
cheese I get it I think I get why it's
so popular this is a banger when you
talk about your beige food Mount
Rushmore this has got to be up there
this is Sesame prawn toast you have four
beige Foods immortalized forever in
stone now if you order a full English
breakfast in the UK you're likely to
find some fried bread on there basically
what Chinese restaurants in the UK have
done is Elevate fried bread by putting a
layer of prawn paste in the middle and
then topping it with loads of sesame
seeds these are delicious I love these
moving on we have the spare ribs I have
to admit I've never had a spare rib it's
not something I've ever ordered these
have bones that's literally a bone I
thought I ordered the boneless spare
ribs but I guess I ordered the spare
ribs with the peeking duck sauce and
they look and smell amazing so I am
going to take a bite anyway yeah that's
literally so good that is so good why
don't I order ribs that's so yummy now I
was shocked when I saw these as an
exclusive in this episode but our next
one is prawn crackers these are another
thing that you'll see on pretty much
every UK Chinese Takeaway order even if
you don't order them often they'll just
throw you in a bag for free they're just
great for like mopping up bits of sauce
or something you can also dip them in
the sweet and sour sauce and you kind of
get this
crackling I really almost hope that
we've made a mistake in this script and
that you can in fact find these on
Chinese takeout menus in the US because
they're great and you guys are missing
out the last two items we wanted to talk
about were chips we have two versions
here that you'll find on pretty much
every British Chinese Takeaway menu we
have regular chips and we have salt and
pepper chips as I'm sure some of you
might know British people don't tend to
have the most adventurous Petes in the
world and there's usually a lot of
demand for chips same with Indian
restaurants and Chinese restaurants
basically they're just catering to the
demand of the British public also it's
very common to pay your chips with curry
sauce so curry sauce in this sense it
probably has some of the similar
flavorings that you would find in like a
katsu curry type sauce I would refer to
this type of curry sauce as like chip
shop curry sauce and that kind of
applies to whether it's Chinese
takeaways or fish and chip shops then we
also have the salt and pepper chips now
salt and pepper seasoning is quite
common at Chinese restaurants in the UK
that refers to a seasoning mix which is
comprised of salt white pepper and
Chinese five spice they kind of take
that base it around it they'll make
chips cook them most of the way and then
finish them usually in a walk with some
chili peppers some onion and some spring
onion these are delicious now I will
defend salt and pepper chips but they
were kind of at the center of that Tik
Tok controversy around British Chinese
food which honestly is kind of why we've
made this episode I also got an order of
fries obviously these are not an
exclusive just to us Chinese takeout
places but I just wanted to show what
they looked like here versus in the UK
very Bland I don't even think these have
salt on them which is kind of
interesting this is definitely one of
those Chinese takeout menu items that
feels very catered to a different kind
of palette I would say that I do not see
people ordering french fries pretty much
ever from a Chinese food place something
like this is probably for like kids who
are picky eaters which I definitely was
I was ordering white rice and chicken
wings from Chinese takeout as a child
because I didn't want to try anything
else but that's what this feels like
something to please the children I'm
calling Harry a child right now
something to please the child another
British Chinese takeout staple is a
crispy aromatic duck pancake now it sits
somewhere kind of between an appetizer
and a main course cuz I mean if you gave
me enough of this I would just eat that
as my main it can be kind of expensive
so I feel like some people just get a
little bit to share so it it's neatly
packaged for us but it comes in a few
different components obviously we have
the crispy aromatic duck itself these
little crispy bits of skin are amazing
we have the pancakes we have hoist in
sauce and then you have your vegetables
in this case we have some Julien
cucumber and spring onion I'll I'll do a
little demo assembly here I feel like
everyone's got different ways of
assembling so don't judge mine start
with a pancake get as much of that
crispy skin as possible couple bits of
Cuke some spions hoison is like kind of
a plum based sauce so it's nice and
sweet works really well with the Savory
have some fun with it you know beautiful
these are Sensational I've not actually
had one of these in a
while
next let's talk about the exclusive soup
options we have this is vegetable bean
curd soup I should mention that I never
order soup when I get Chinese takeout
but I it's obviously going to vary from
person to person some people like a
little soup appetizer I'm not one of
those
people although I love soup in general
it mostly just smells like broccoli to
me it doesn't have a super strong flavor
I feel like the broth isn't as rich as I
wanted it to be but the tofu is really
tasty next we have the hot and sour sour
I've never had hot and sour soup before
so I am interested to try it this smells
a lot like sweet and sour sauce so I
assume that that's what's in here I'm
seeing vegetables what I think is tofu
it smells really good so let's take a
little
slurp the texture is not my favorite I
think it's like got the texture of a
sauce to me so like sipping it like a
soup doesn't feel right but it does
taste good and lastly we have the egg
drop soup which I feel like is a pretty
popular soup when you're ordering
Chinese takeout here the one we got here
is chicken and sweet corn which I think
is kind of like the archetypal Chinese
Takeaway soup here in the UK I won't
necessarily go out of my way to order
one of these although I do think they're
pretty tasty one thing to point out
though is the texture of these cuz if
you're not used to it it can really take
you by surprise there's something about
a chicken and sweet corn soup in
particular that's just so comforting we
actually do have a corn and chicken soup
here too I just don't think it's as
popular as something like a hot and sour
soup in the UK we have a lot of fried
rice dishes these probably could be be
ordered as your main meal but I would
say in the UK they're more traditionally
ordered alongside a meat or a vegetable
dish and kind of enjoyed together we
picked out a couple of options here is
the house special fried rice and then
also we have the Singapore fried rice I
just wanted to find out what makes this
the house special fried rice because
usually it will include a variation of
kind of things mixed in with it there's
little pieces of chicken pork and prawn
in here as well as some spring onions
the Singapore fried rice seems to
actually have the same fillings I'm
seeing these little tiny shrimps in them
seeing bits of chicken and pork as well
but I think this is supposed to be a
slightly spicier fried rice so let me
give this one a quick
try not like overpoweringly hot but
definitely more of a chili kick to that
one moving on to our fried rice option
we only have one and this is the Young
Chow fried rice it's basically made with
a bunch of different protein options
looking down right now I just see Spar
ribs I see chicken icy shrimp looks kind
of good I've never thought of eating
multiple Meats at one time like this
this I would argue and say that fried
rice in general is like a popular food
here I make it all the time like it's
such an easy dish to make at home and
it's definitely popular at Chinese
takeout places but for some reason we
only had one exclusive option at this
particular location I'm going to try to
get a bite with every single meat on it
oh there it
is it is a very odd taste when it's
three different Meats at once but it's
not bad it's actually pretty good now
chelman has be one of the most popular
dishes in the UK I think surveys have
actually placed it as the number one
dish it's pretty versatile I say usually
again this would be an accompaniment to
maybe like a meat Dish as well or you
could kind of just eat this on its own
personally chicken Chowan is my favorite
and I think probably most Brit's
favorite too but you can also just get
plain vegetable or various other
toppings here we have the chicken Chowan
it's effectively just a stir fried
noodle dish Chowan definitely is a thing
here it just isn't a thing at this
particular restaurant I'm sorry I have
to repeat myself so much let's talk
noodles this is the pan fried noodle
this is the Lan and this is the
Singapore mayun opening this up I knew
exactly what it smelled like it smells
like Curry so there has to be some sort
of Curry element in it it smells really
good so I think I'm going to take a bite
I've never had this before and it also
looks like they use a smaller noodle
than in either of these two dishes it's
like those thin is it like vermicelli
noodles vermicelli noodles that's my
daughter's
name this dish also has multiple
proteins going on I'm seeing chicken and
I'm seeing shrimp I don't know if
there's anything else underneath but
that's what I see right now the flavor's
pretty good I don't know if I like
vermell noodles I think this is my first
time having them they're just such a
thin noodle I like something chewier
like the ones that come in the Little M
once you get past the rice and the
noodle portions the Chinese Takeaway
menus in the UK are usually categorized
by protein so you'll choose either
chicken pork beef or anything else and
then you kind of choose a sauce that
goes with that for example we can get
sweet and sour chicken but you can also
get sweet and sour pork and sweet and
sour beef from each protein category
we're going to show you a couple of
either interesting or unique food items
let's start with chicken here I have
lemon chicken this is another one of
those that's probably going to be found
on pretty much every Chinese Takeaway
menu in the UK the sauce is pretty good
though it's lemony a little bit sweet a
little bit tart then here we have the
kungo chicken you might also see this
referred to as kungpow chicken with that
a in the middle there but it's the same
dish it's basically not too dissimilar
to sweet and sour chicken that you might
find on the menu at a UK Chinese takeout
it's these dredged and fried pieces of
chicken in a sweet and spicy sauce
kungpow chicken I think traditionally
also would have some peanut in it in the
US it's exactly the same our menus are
categorized by the protein type but a
lot of the dishes are really different
so you don't always get the same sauce
for say a seafood Dish as you would a
chicken dish let's start with the chopi
which I have never had before but I'm
very interested you can get it with any
protein we got ours with chicken and
here's what that looks like the chicken
looks a little
pale I feel like this is a surprisingly
Bland dish compared to a lot of other
chicken dishes I've had from Chinese
takeout it's definitely not my favorite
moving on to the sesame chicken this was
like a fan favorite I was told I had to
get this I'm not a sesame chicken
orderer but my friends and co-workers
are yeah it's so good next we have
orange chicken which as the name
suggests has orange in the sauce and
this particular place uses like the
orange peel to like season the chicken
I've definitely had a lot of orange
chicken in my day particularly the
Frozen kind from Trader Joe's so it is
pretty popular it's not a spicy sauce
it's definitely just like a sweet Tangy
sauce but it's very delicious and last
but not least we have General s chicken
which is my personal favorite thing to
order from Chinese takeout you'll see it
on a lot of Chinese restaurant menus
here in the US but it's not exactly
authentic Chinese food shocker General
sa was a real General from the Hunan
Province who supposedly enjoyed eating a
dish similar to General sa chicken
although This Modern American version
would probably be unrecognizable to him
the dish was actually created in the
1950s by a chef named Pang Chang Quay
when he immigrated to New York in 1973
he altered his recipe to cater to the
American palette which in this case
means he made it sweeter Pang Chen qu
called it general sa's chicken because
he and general sa are from the same town
then we're on to the beef options now
firstly I have to shout out what might
be my favorite British Chinese Takeaway
dish which is crispy shredded beef with
chili one thing I've got to say talking
a lot about textures and crispiness here
what you will often find from Chinese
takeaways in the UK they actually break
a little hole in the plastic container
this is probably the first thing that
I'm ordering when I'm ordering a Chinese
Takeaway what they do is they get these
little slivers of beef dredge them
usually in something like cornflour fry
them up and then toss them in this
lovely sweet and spicy chili sauce I
just love the variation you get like
some of them will be slightly chewier
some of them will be
crispier flavors are great next up we
have some sesan beef now I really
enjoyed hearing Taran talking about the
cooking with the peppercorn when we were
doing the US versus China series go
check that out but I think sesan food
tends to be pretty spicy and they also
use sesan pepper corns which give you
this kind of like numbing effect in your
mouth the beef here also isn't fried
it's more just like pieces of brazed
beef I'm kind of intrigued to give this
a try although I'm worried about my
spice
tolerance yeah it's pretty spicy it's
very tasty very flavorful and then
finally we've got some beef in black
bean sauce I'd say this is a pretty
common one as well and this is one that
you can also get in different meat
varieties so you can get this with the
chicken with the pork anything else
comes with loads of peppers as well some
chili in there onions it's a nice like
very rich sauce that's really good that
with some rice beautiful pairing we'll
often actually get this one this is one
of my favorites I feel like I've said
that about a lot of things I think I
just ordered too much Chinese Takeaway
there's a variety of beef dishes that
you can get at Chinese food places here
in America today we got the Mushu beef
so it's got cabbage some mushrooms
obviously the beef let's take a taste
the beef in that is really really tender
and delicious I actually really like
this Seafood is also a pretty common
option on UK Chinese Takeaway menus a
lot of the options you will find have
similar sources to some of the beef or
pork options but there are also a few
unique ones as well firstly we have have
salt and pepper squid you might remember
the salt and pepper chips from earlier
it's basically crispy squid cooked in
that same seasoning sometimes this might
be found under appetizers today they had
it in their main section so we're going
with that I love crispy squid the way
that they kind of like cut it with this
cross-hatch pattern particularly in
Chinese cuisine gives it a really nice
texture it's not that chewy it's really
flavorful not super fishy just to
illustrate that sometimes the sauces are
the same in different parts of the menu
this is the pepper and black bean sauce
again but this time with squid then we
have a couple of prawn options as well
here we have the king prawns in oyster
sauce and King prawns with cashew nuts
while we have the prawn here in its uh
unbolded form let me get one of those
out Nico how does that look is that a
prawn or a shrimp or neither that prawn
kind of looks shrimpy to me it certainly
does not look like a king prawn that's
not the king of the prawns in the US
shrimp is definitely the most popular
seafood option when you get Chinese
takeout we have a couple of shrimp
options here the sesan shrimp and a
seafood Delight which has shrimp in it
and I'm guessing other delightful sea
creatures that's just shrimp is that
what is delightful or do they mean
Delight is like you get a bunch of
veggies with it let's just try the sesan
shrimp it smells as spicy as I think
it's going to be this is probably the
biggest shrimp I've seen
today I swear I've eaten with a fork
before Oh No it's tailon it's spicy not
as spicy as I thought it was is going to
be but I'm sure the more you eat it the
spicier it gets but that sauce is really
really good and the shrimp is awesome
even though it's got tails on it take
the tails off we also got a shrimp egg
roll Harry really wanted me to try this
and I'm glad he mentioned it because
I've never had a shrimp egg roll before
just pork that's what I get every time
do you see that one little tiny piece of
shrimp I feel like it tastes slightly
different than the pork not just because
the meat is different another item
you'll see in a lot of Chinese
restaurants in the US is egg fu young
it's an omelet made with vegetables a
protein and a stir fry sauce wao baby
this is a big omelette it smells really
good it doesn't just smell like egg it
smells like a lot of good stuff it needs
a lot more salt actually I wonder if
you're supposed to like add sauce or
something on top I think we're actually
supposed to add this gravy to it so let
me add that and see if it helps with the
salt Factor this feels very UK core
right now me pouring this gravy all over
food better still not great I don't know
if I like this yeah EG for young looks
interesting but I'm not sure British
people would really be going in and kind
of ordering just an omelette from a
Chinese Takeaway I'm not sure how well
that would take off over here it's time
for sauce talk sauce talk if there was
ever a time to do sauce talk it's now so
in front of me here I have all the
sources that were on offer at the
restaurant we ordered from I'm going to
go through them now explain what they
are what they might be paired with and
give them a try we'll start with a
slightly Infamous one it's British curry
sauce the British went around the world
took spices from everybody and this is
somehow the only thing that we came up
with Brits love curry sauce or at least
this iteration of curry
sauce there's definitely like some heat
there not a lot it's quite a gentle
spice flavor there's something about the
texture that is just really satisfying
that really gloopy like corn starchy
texture goes excellently with chicken
balls you'll often see Brits drizzling
this onto chick chips chips and curry
sauce is a big thing in the UK or you'll
just see it drizzled across your entire
succulent Chinese meal I was say Joe
really loved that when we did our Fish
and Chips shop Food Tours episode it's
not just the Brits who can enjoy it then
we have another iconic UK Chinese
takeout sauce which is sweet and sour
depending on where you get it from the
color again will vary it's a pretty well
balanced one the first thing that hits
your tongue is the sour then it pretty
quickly Mellows out and you get a nice
sweet aftertaste again I think this is
kind of intended to be paired with the
chicken balls or prawn balls or
something else like that but I do think
a lot of Brits will just kind of coat
entire meal in it while we're on the
subject of these iconic sources I also
have to shout out the poyene cups I
think Americans might call that
styrofoam but these are really iconic
this is the standard delivery vessel for
your sources the restaurant that we
ordered from had two chili options
firstly we have sweet chili Brits love
sweet chili this is on the menu at a lot
of restaurants and then the next one we
have is chili oil I'd say this one isn't
super commonly found on like UK Chinese
takeout menus next up we have the black
bean sauce now this is the same sauce
that you might have seen in some of the
dishes earlier then we got two more
sauces first up we have hoisen sauce now
this is most commonly paired with the
crispy duck that you'll find on UK
Chinese takeout menus it's a very thick
dark brown sauce again gloopy sauces we
love it I think the main ingredient in
hoisting sauce or one of the main
ingredients is plum so you get this real
sweetness from it which works very well
with the Savory duck meat and other
things on the menu and then finally we
have barbecue sauce now I was a little
bit confused when I saw this on the menu
because barbecue sauce in the kind of
Western sense so like a Texas barbecue
sauce for example does not look like
this and I think that's what I was
expecting but I think what's actually
being delivered is much more of a
Chinese style barbecue sauce what this
one makes me think of is more when you
eat like a charu pork bun for example
cuz while it is barbecuey it's still got
some sweetness to it there's Chinese
five spice in here but if you're
expecting like Hines barbecue sauce
that's not it I think out of all of
these ones the one I will reach for the
most will be the sweeten sour sauce it's
because I'll almost always order the
chicken balls when I'm making a Chinese
takeout order in the UK and one of these
will come with it yeah I think in the UK
it's kind of just the definitive Source
closely followed by Curry I think that's
one of the biggest differences between
Chinese takeout in the US us and the UK
our takeout comes with the sauce already
Incorporated for the most part you do
get a mix though of tiny little sauce
packets like this so we've got soy sauce
Duck Sauce which is so good it's kind of
just like a sweet sauce we have mustard
usually which I'm not seeing here but
you do get mustard and hot sauce I'm
pretty sure there are more but that's
just what we have right now and then we
have a couple little cups of this looks
like a paste I think that this is a
little tiny container of oyster sauce
and this is just a little container of
extra soy sauce probably for dipping if
you do not have a drawer full of these
sauces I don't know what you're doing I
feel like everybody has that drawer in
their house that's filled with random
sauce packets like
this now that we've covered every item
individually what I wanted to do was
show you my ideal plate of British
Chinese Takeaway food you might have
seen these on Tik Tok or elsewhere as
these kind of broke the internet a while
ago but I'm going to show you my version
I need some
chowman the amount of carbs that might
end up on this plate could be alarming
to some cuz we're going to go noodles
also going to go rice you know we're
going to get the salt and pepper chips
involved then I want a healthy portion
of my crispy chili beef I'm going to
want some seaweed on here some of this
prawn toast definitely a couple of
spring rolls and of course our prawn
crackers as well so genuinely speaking
this is a pretty normal plate of Chinese
Takeaway food for a British person but
we're not done there the final step of
course is to add our sauces yes that SAU
is plural because we're going to be
adding both the curry sauce and the
sweet and sour sauce to this and
honestly I'm not discriminating here
this is going pretty much on the entire
meal and of course our sweet and sour
sauce love it or hate it that is your
typical plate of British Chinese
Takeaway food I think I've done a pretty
good job there British people please
feel free to agree or disagree with me
in the comments below Nico I've got to
hear your thoughts about this would you
eat this let me stop you right there why
do you guys sauce the whole plate like
doesn't the whole plate just then taste
like that sauce you want everything to
taste exactly like that sauce bone up
the teeth now let's make up an American
plate of Chinese takeout with a bunch of
staple foods that I think are pretty
nationally beloved I would say let's
start with our sides our little
appetizers so we'd probably throw a
couple of wontons on there I'd also do
some type of roll I would usually do an
egg roll but all we've got left are
spring rolls next you'd have your rice I
prefer white rice I just think it's
really easy to pair with any sort of
entree okay I wouldn't normally eat the
full container rice but we're going to
keep it on the plate we got to get some
chicken you definitely need a side of
veg so we're going to do broccoli cuz I
feel like that's literally at every
single Chinese restaurant they have
broccoli on the side if you ignore the
huge mountain of white rice I think this
looks pretty appetizing the last thing I
would add to this plate is probably some
lowain so let's do that I didn't mention
these before but these little fried I
think they're fried noodle pieces they
come with soups so you can just throw
them in your soup have them with your
soup they're just good to snack on I
think this looks like a pretty
appetizing plate this is probably the
point where folks in the UK would douse
their plate in sauce I would do things a
little differently I really like dipping
egg rolls into the Duck Sauce which is
this one it's so good and some people
put sauce I think over their rice and
stuff so we have our white rice our
wontons our fried noodles some spring
rolls a side of broccoli sesame chicken
and the low man which I think this kind
of sums up what a typical order from a
Chinese food place would look like here
in
America if it doesn't look like what you
would order
sorry babe I don't know what to tell you
this is just what I think I can't even
believe I didn't mention it yet you have
to get a can of Coke on the side any
soft drink really will do I just think
you need a can of soda with your Chinese
takeout it's just it's a sensation like
no other it's it goes
together in the UK when we order food to
be delivered we say we're ordering a
takeaway rather than ordering takeout
also in the okay we tend not to bother
adding the words food or takeaway to the
type of food we're eating for example if
we're ordering Chinese takeout most
Brits will just say that we're having a
Chinese same applies for maybe Indian
food when you have an Indian or even a
full English breakfast in the US we call
it takeout they obviously both mean the
same thing but that's just our preferred
way of saying it we also say Chinese
food or Chinese takeout rather than just
a Chinese we also wanted to look at how
each country packages its food in the UK
you might find your Chinese food in one
of these foil boxes with a paper lid the
other most common form of packaging is
one of these clear plastic tubs and then
finally for your appetizer options such
as some spring rolls which we've got
here they generally will just come in a
paper bag I've always seen those folded
cardboard boxes in American TV shows and
they do look pretty cool I have to say
also the cute little takeout boxes are
something that I feel like we see a lot
maybe in media when someone orders
Chinese food but they're not super super
common mostly the food comes in these
kinds of containers which is like a
black Tupperware with a clear top these
are usually reserved for the rice maybe
the L main but it's not reserved for
like all of the food options these boxes
were actually inspired by Japanese
origami Frederick weeks Wilcox was the
first person to introduce the paper pale
box in the 19th century to carry raw
oysters he created a patent for it and
called it a paper pale which it
basically is it's like a cute little
pale in the UK and the US portion sizes
and menu items will vary slightly
depending on the different restaurants
that you go to but we did want to
compare a couple of standard menu items
in the US and the UK to see who might be
getting bigger portions one iconic
appetizer from a Chinese Takeaway in the
UK is the spring roll the restaurant
that we ordered from serves these in a
portion size of six in the US spring
rolls are made a little bit differently
they're made with rice paper and they
have thinly sliced vegetables on the
inside this particular Chinese
restaurant only gave us two but I have
ordered from some places that give you
more just depends on where you order
from we do have egg rolls which are kind
of similar to the UK these come in only
one size as as far as I know but
depending on what place you order from
they could be like a little bit bigger a
little bit smaller than this my local
place they're actually a little bit
bigger than this size in the UK our egg
fried rice only came in one size I don't
want to weigh this outside of the box so
I'm just going to weigh it in the Box
this is a mountain all of this rice just
came out of this tiny little container
so this is what our fried rice looks
like at this particular restaurant they
only had one size of this fried rice but
I have seen places do small and large
sizes all all right let's weigh this
mountain of
rice it's like just maxed out the scales
that's a lot of rice we do have chicken
included in that just letting you know
and we did weigh the plate beforehand so
that's not part of this weight the
restaurant that we ordered from had Chow
in two different sizes regular and large
although the large was only available
with certain varieties so this is a
chicken chow regular size and this is
the house special chow main in a large
size we do have Chow here in America but
we didn't have it at this particular
restaurant we do have pan fried noodles
which I think are similarish so we're
going to weigh these although I feel
like it might once again be slightly too
heavy for the scales moving on to sweet
and sour chicken that is like a tried
and true classic with takeout I think
that I'm supposed to Sauce it myself
which isn't the norm for me in my
experience getting Chinese takeout
everything is already like Sauced you
don't need to add anything this time
they came without sauce so we're just
going to add it ourselves in the UK our
sweet and sour chicken came in one size
in the UK this consists of little fried
pieces of chicken peppers onions and
also pineapple I'm getting word that I
think I was supposed to dip the
individual pieces into sauce and eat it
like that I've never ordered this I just
know it's a common takeout item year but
I already poured the sauce all over it
so let's just wait and see how much it
is as we mentioned before each Chinese
restaurant is unique as to how they
prepare and cook their food so it's kind
of possible to know exactly what's going
into each dish one ingredient that we
did want to highlight however as it's
commonly associated with Chinese food is
MSG or monosodium glutamate in 1907 a
Japanese chemist named kikuna ikada
discovered a substance called glutamate
also known as Umami he later broke that
substance down into MSG MSG is a
seasoning and food enhancer that gives a
rich Savory flavor MSG is actually very
commonly found in fast foods including
Chick-fil-A snack foods including
Doritos and naturally occurs in some
cheeses MSG has been recognized as is
safe by the FDA several times and only
contains a third of the sodium content
of table salt so why's it got such a bad
rap in 1968 the New England Journal of
Medicine published a letter titled
Chinese restaurant syndrome in it a
doctor describes his experiences after
eating at Chinese restaurants citing
symptoms like numbness in the back of
the neck General weakness and
palpitations the blame was placed on MSG
and the Chinese restaurant syndrome myth
quickly spread the phrase even ended up
in the marry and Webster dictionary
despite there being no evidence that MSG
was dangerous there was still a public
panic around it Chinese restaurants in
particular were deemed unhealthy
thankfully the use of MSG is much more
normalized today although the xenophobic
misinformation from the 196s does still
linger if you Google MSG some of the
suggested Search terms include things
like why are Americans afraid of MSG and
is MSG a neurotoxin short answer no it's
not the first Chinese restaurants to
appear in the UK were called eating
houses they would serve Chinese Sailors
who would dock in British ports this
goes as far back as the 19th century
when Hong Kong was part of the British
Empire notable locations for this
included Limehouse which is part of the
East End of London and was actually
where the original Chinatown was the
East End of London was particularly hit
by bombing raids in the second world war
which caused Chinatown to relocate to
Soho where it is today the first
recorded Cantonese restaurant in London
was a place called Cafe and it was
opened in 1908 it was opened by a former
ship's Chef a guy called Chun Kun it was
chun's son who opened a restaurant in
baywater decades later which might have
been the kind of origin of the Chinese
Takeaway in London apparently the food
was so popular that if customers
couldn't get at a table they would
simply ask for the food to go Chun kun's
restaurant Maxim had a very popular dish
consisting of pork and a sweet and sour
sauce called ja Jiao while the origins
of the dish are specifically Cantonese
it just became known as Chinese food to
Britains the first known Chinese
restaurant in the US was called Canton
and opened in 1849 in San Francisco the
1850s saw the appeal of the gold rush so
to escape worst conditions in China
there was a flood of Chinese immigrants
in this time restaurants began popping
up to feed Chinese workers who missed
their Cuisine from home modifying their
favorite dishes using ingredient inred
that they could find in the US in 1882
the Chinese Exclusion Act forbade
Chinese immigrants from Coming to
America an exception was made for
restaurant tours who could apply for
merchant visas which saw a boom in
Chinese restaurants opening up in the
1910s any new restaurants that opened
had to be considered high grade to be
within the 1882 act so the owners
lavishly decorated the restaurants and
by 1943 the Act was revoked during this
period dishes such as chopi and EG Fu
Young were popularized across the
country especially the spread of chops
houses chapsui was made from food scraps
its name basically means leftovers male
migrants who came over from China had
little to no kitchen skills and
ingredients were different from those
back home so they threw together what
they could find creating a dish that was
very easy to make chopi was a popular
Chinese American dish up until the 1960s
after which general so's chicken kind of
became the new popular thing also during
this time Chinese food began to be
preserved in cans for pickling and
freezing because the Great Depression
meant that people were looking for food
that was more affordable popularizing
the chopi houses was a turning point for
integrating Chinese cuisine into
American culture even if the dish was
eventually less popular Chinese food
increased in popularity in the UK during
and after World War II recipes for
Chinese Cakes as well as other simple
Chinese recipes were introduced to Brits
by the BBC and as some Brits returned
from being stationed in the Far East
they brought back with them a taste for
Chinese cuisine an influx of Cantonese
immigrants arriving from Hong Kong in
the 1950s brought with it a wave of
Chinese restaurants to the UK these
restaurants really blew up in popularity
the restaurants proved so popular in
fact that Billy butland introduced chopi
and chips to the restaurant menus at his
holiday camps one Trend that you also
saw was Chinese families taking over old
fish and chip restaurants this is why
you still see things like fish and chips
or battered sausage and chips on the
menu at some Chinese restaurants around
1960 The Mandarin opened in San
Francisco introducing Americans to
Chinese food Beyond chop sooi like hot
and sour soup and pot stickers Cecilia
Chang the owner of the restaurant wasn't
sure what food customers would want so
she added over 300 items to the menu
President Nixon's trip to China in 1972
began to normalize relations between the
countries and Americans were influenced
to try more Chinese food in 1989 the
National Restaurant Association
concluded that Chinese food was actually
the most frequently consumed Cuisine
across the country and over the next few
decades the number of Chinese
restaurants went up by the thousands in
2007 there were over 43,000 in the US
today there are over 23,000 Chinese
restaurants in the 1950s there were only
36 Chinese restaurants in the UK but the
next few decades saw that number rapidly
Ascend by the late 1990s that number had
risen to over 5,000 today there are a
little over 7,000 Chinese restaurants up
and down the UK according to a survey
Chinese food is the second most popular
cuisine in the US right behind Pizza as
of June 2023 a 2001 poll said that
Chinese food was British people's
favorite foreign Cuisine this was backed
up by another poll 20 years later which
said that 25% of Brits will still up for
Chinese as their favorite foreign
Cuisine that's really good I love
duck I think there's a direct
correlation between how cute an animal
is and how good it tastes cuz ducks are
pretty adorable and damn are they
tasty